- I'm y'all's substitute
teacher, Mr. Garvey.
- I am your substitute,
Mr. Nostrand.
- I'm Sir Bruce Michaels,
- I'm T Ray Tombstone.
- Settle in and like just totally,
let's get our math on, okay?
(hiphop music)
- [Announcer] Teaching
center is brought to you by
BMW, the ultimate driving machine.
(upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to Teaching Center.
I'm Boyd Maxwell with today's top stories
from the exciting world of teaching.
- And I'm Perry Schmidt.
- Well, now we know.
The long awaited announcement
by star English teacher,
Ruby Ruhf has sent teaching
fans across the nation
into a frenzy.
- I've enjoyed my time in Ohio very much
but I'm pleased to announce
that I'm taking my talents
back to New York City.
Thank you very much.
- Apparently PS 431 has made Ruby an offer
she couldn't refuse,
$80 million guaranteed
over six years, with another 40 million
in incentives based on test scores.
This salary puts you right up there
with Rockridge Elementary's Katie Hope
and William Wu, out of
- Colgate Magnet.
(hands slap)
All right, let's take a look
at yesterday's high school teacher draft
from Radio City Music Hall,
where Central Rapids High, recipient
of the worst test scores last semester,
made the first pick.
That was no surprise to anyone.
(audience applauds)
- For the first pick,
Central Rapids High takes,
calculus teacher, Mike Yoast
from Tulsa Teachers College.
(audience cheers)
- [Boyd] And just like
that, you're a millionaire.
- [Perry] Mike Yoast is
an unbelievable story.
His father living from
paycheck to paycheck
as a humble pro football player,
kid was a natural mathlete.
- You know, he is gonna
buy his mom a house.
- [Perry] Oh, you know this?
- Oh, there's no way around that.
(laughs)
You owe your mom.
- [Announcer] Today's
highlight of the day is brought
to you by the 100% Black
Angus beef thick burger
on a fresh-baked bun from
Carl's Jr. and Hardee's.
- Now it's time for the
highlight of the day.
- Star history teacher, Ashley
Ferguson has been running
up them test scores over
at Vince Corkle High.
- Yep, okay.
- Woo!
- Confederate forces fired first.
Can anyone tell me where
this battle took place?
- Now look at this.
She looks left then right.
Looks past the students with their arms up
in the air, spots Max, near the back,
sees that even though his
hand isn't up, he's engaged.
- Max?
- It was at Fort Sumter.
- That's right.
- Oh, come on, see what she did there?
She's bringing an introvert
into the discussion.
Y'all, that's a teacher of
the year play, right there.
That's right, Boyd.
You know the confidence
game by Max by answering
that question correctly
will enhance his performance
throughout the rest of the year.
- No doubt.
Coming up after the break,
Mayfield Prep trades
French teacher, Janine
Lowe to Skyline High
for a head librarian and two
lunch ladies to be named later.
- And we'll get the inside scoop
on the impending teacher's strike.
- [Boyd] Uh-oh.
- That could cripple the season.
- Next up on Teaching Center.
- Woohoo.
- [Teacher] Strength courses through me.
I am velocity.
I am power.
I am a leader, a believer.
I am the force
that guides.
I am the gateway to what is possible.
The path to the future.
I am the future.
- The all new 2015 6-series is here.
Meet the new teacher's pet.
(bell rings)
- All right, listen up, y'all.
I'm y'all's substitute
teacher, Mr. Garvey.
I taught school for 20
years in the inner city.
So don't even think about messing with me.
Y'all feel me?
Okay.
Let's take a roll here.
Jay Quellan?
Where's Jay Quellan at?
No Jay Quellan here?
Yeah.
- Do you mean Jaclyn?
- Okay, so that's how it's going to be.
Y'all wanna play.
Okay, then, I've got my
eye on you, Jay Quellan.
Ba-LAK-a?
Where is Ba-LAK-a at?
No Ba-LAK-a here today?
Yes, sir?
- My name's Blake.
- Are you outta your goddam mind?
Blake?
What?
Do you wanna go to war Ba-LAK-a?
- No.
- 'Cause we could go to war.
- [Blake] No.
- I'm for real, I'm for real.
So you better check yourself.
- Dee Nice?
Is there a Dee Nice?
If one of y'all says some silly ass name,
this whole class is
going to feel my wrath.
Now Dee Nice.
- Do you mean Denise?
- Son of a bitch.
You say your name right, right now.
- Denise?
- Say it right.
- Denise.
- Correctly?
- Right?
- Denise.
- Dee Nice.
- That's better, thank you.
- Now, A A-ron.
Where are you?
Where is a A A-ron right now?
No A A-ron, huh?
Well, you better be sick,
dead, or mute A A-ron.
- Here, oh man.
- Why didn't you answer me
the first time I said it?
- Huh?
- I'm just, you know, I'm
just asking, you know,
I said it like four times.
So why didn't you say it the
first time I said a A A-ron?
- Because it's pronounced Aaron?
- Son of a bitch.
(books crash)
You done messed up A-A-ron.
Now take your ass on down to
O Shack Hennessy's office,
right now, and tell him
exactly what you did.
- Who?
- O Shack Hennessy.
- Principal O'Shaughnessy?
- Get outta my goddam classroom
before I break my foot off in your ass.
Insubordinate,
and churlish.
Tim MO thee?
- Present.
- Thank you.
(bell rings)
All right, gonna take a little roll here,
Jay Quellan.
- Here
- You are present.
Ba-LAK-a?
- Right here.
- Uh-huh.
Dee Nice.
- Here.
- Good,
Ja-SEEK-a?
Thank you.
- Mr. Garvey?
- What is A A-ron?
- Some of us need to leave
a few minutes early today.
- Oh.
- Oh, is that so?
- Um-hmm.
- And what, pray tell,
is the reason
for this premature exodus?
- Yearbook photos.
We have to leave 15 minutes early
to meet up with our clubs.
- All right, you know what?
That might work with
other substitute teachers.
But I taught in inner
city for over 20 years.
Now y'all wanna leave my class early,
so y'all can go meet up at the club.
Ain't none of y'all old
enough to go to the damn club!
Ridiculous.
- Mr. Garvey?
- God, son of a bitch.
Did I st-st-st-stutter just then?
Yes.
I'm gonna throw you out the goddam window.
What, Jay Quellan?
- Mr. Garvey, we're telling the truth.
We, we have clubs at this school.
We have clubs for special interests.
- Okay, I see.
So y'all wanna play.
Y'all wanna play?
Yeah okay, we're gonna play little games.
Fine, I'll play.
I'm more than happy to
play some games with y'all.
Anyone who's in a club, stand your ass up.
Uh-huh, oh yeah, there it is, there it is.
The usual suspects.
What the hell club are
you in, Jay Quellan?
- Future Leaders of America.
- Okay, okay.
How would you know if
you're gonna be a leader
in the future?
Is there a star gate in your bedroom?
Can you travel through time, Jay Quellan?
- No.
- Then sit the flip down.
- Ba-LAK-a, I, here's the thing.
I don't even know why I'm
about to ask you this.
Ba-LAK-a, what club are you in?
I'm part of the Spanish Club.
- Sp, this, you about as Spanish
as Reeon Seacrest,
with your big-ass Fraggel Rock hair.
How about you Dee Nice.
- I'm in the Chess Club.
- Uh, I'm sorry, sweetheart.
You are not in the chest club.
The mosquito bite club, maybe.
- Oh, it's hurtful.
- Truthful.
There he is A A-ron.
- Hey.
- What club are you in?
- I'm the president of the Glee Club.
Why do I talk?
- The glee club?
(books crash)
Like they gonna have a club
dedicated to a TV show.
Take your to O Shack
Hennessy's office right now,
before I bust a club up in your butt.
- Okay.
- Go..
- Okay, I'm gonna go.
- Mischievous and deceitful.
Chicanerous and deplorable.
- [Intercom Voice] This is
principal O'Shaughnessy.
Students, please report to the gymnasium
for your club photos.
- Fake announcement.
Now does anybody in
here have a valid reason
for leaving this classroom?
- Ti-MO-thee?
- I gotta go pick up my daughter?
- You're excused.
(bell rings)
- Okay, all right everybody,
just let's settle down,
settle in, and like, just totally,
let's get our math on, okay?
All right guys.
(class laughs)
- All right Jimmy.
Somebody's got a little extra energy,
from Phys Ed, right?
Jimmy, buddy.
Hey buddy, let's, okay, it's
just, let's knock it off, okay?
(class laughs)
- Knock it off.
You got me.
He got me right guys?
Jimmy, dude.
All let's take our seat.
Look at me.
(class laughs)
That's great,
that's great,
that's great.
Very good, bravo Jimmy.
I'm just kidding.
You guys can clap.
(classroom applauds)
That was awesome.
Oh, and I thank you.
I thank you for the entertainment, man.
(Jimmy indistinctly verbalizes )
(class laughs)
Jimmy, let's go man.
Hey, buddy, I don't wanna
harsh your vibe, man, but-
- Ah, Eureka!
- I'm gonna be honest with you.
You're really pushing
my buttons now, Jimmy.
(Jimmy indistinctly verbalizes)
You're driving me crazy, man.
(class laughs)
- Eh, zoom, eh digga, digga, digga, digga.
- That's enough.
Do you want me to write
your name on the board?
(Jimmy screams)
- Okay, Jimmy, do you want
me to call Principal Martel?
That would not be bitchin', would it?
You know what, Jimmy?
You know what?
Why don't you come up
and teach the class, man?
Hmm, wouldn't that be awesome?
- Moi?
- Yeah, come on up.
(class laughs)
No, and then you know
what I'm gonna do, Jimmy?
I'll just sit here, how about that Jimmy,
and then we can all watch
how you're being disruptive.
(Jimmy indistinctly verbalizes)
(class laughs)
Oh, I see, that's
supposed to be me, right.
All right, Jimmy, okay.
I see, I get it's supposed to be me.
It's time to be done, Jimmy.
Don't you dare, Jimmy.
(class laughs)
Oh, yeah?
Oh, yeaaaaahhhhh?
Well this is you, Jimmy.
(teacher indistinctly verbalizes)
I'm you, Jimmy.
How about that, Jimmy, huh?
Oh, I wanna slap five, gimmie five.
Gimmie five.
(hands slap)
Huh? How about that, huh?
That's you Jimmy.
I'm Jimmy.
I'm Jimmy
and I need attention.
Yeah, I'm Jimmy.
I'm Jimmy.
Hell, look at there.
Happy moment, that's the funniest thing
that ever happened in the whole world.
I'm Jimmy.
I want attention.
(teacher indistinctly verbalizes)
I'm Jimmy, I'm Jimmy.
(teacher indistinctly verbalize)
- Mr. Pryor.
- Principal Martel.
No, what?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, it was Jimmy.
It was Jimmy, Principal Martel.
No, Jimmy.
It was Jimmy,
it was Jimmy,
it was Jimmy.
(class cheers)
- [Class Chanters] Jimmy,
Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy,
Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy.
(dramatic music)
(bell rings)
(class chatters)
(door slams)
- I
am your substitute,
Mr. Nostrand.
But that might as well say no nonsense,
because I do not play.
Now today will not be a day off.
In fact, today you will work harder than,
(Mr. Nostrand farts)
(class laughs)
(class cheers, shouts)
- [Student] See you later Mr. Poopstrand.
(class laughs)
- What up, homie?
Welcome to
- [In Unison] cunnilingus class.
- I'm Sir Bruce Michaels.
- I'm T Ray Tombstone.
And we're here to teach y'all how to,
- [In Unison] Go down on bitches right.
Now, bitches ain't being
satisfied, so check it.
- Quit (beep) on that
clitoris so damn hard.
- Bitches don't like that nonsense.
- That's like putting the tip
of your penis in the vacuum.
- Y'all need to-
- [In Unison] Chill on the clitoris.
- Go around that business.
- That's like a button made
of a million penis tops.
Now every bitch like her
cunnilingus a little bit different.
- Vaginas are like snowflakes.
- Snowflakes is different.
Learn yo bitch's snowflake.
- Ask your what she wants.
- [In Unison] Then do what she says.
- Some bitches like it in a circles.
- Some bitches like it up and down.
- Some like it hard.
- Some like its soft.
- [In Unison] Communicate
with your bitches.
- Make the alphabet with your tongue.
- A,
B,
C,
D-
- And when she grab your hair,
like she gonna pull your damn head off.
- [Intercom Voice] Stick with that letter.
- I'm talking about B b b b b b
- Or D d d d d d
- [In Unison] Vaginas deserve respect.
- You don't want someone slapping
around your little homie.
- Ah, ah, ah, ah.
- You with the hat?
- Yo.
- How you like your BJs?
- Damn dog all the time.
- Shut the (beep up).
- [T Ray] That's 'cause penises is easy.
- And vaginas is hard.
- They're-
- [In Unison] Confusing.
- Imagine there's an explosion
at the envelope factory.
- Flaps everywhere, a world of flaps.
- And you need to lick
your way out the factory.
- But every bitch's flaps is different.
- Learn your bitch's particular flaps.
- Flaps be-
- [In Unison] Crazy.
- Every flap need to be listened to.
- And then you will get
outta the factory alive.
- Stay down there.
- [In Unison] Plan your
breathing like you're swimming.
- You gotta be talking about,
- [In Unison] Stroke, stroke, breathe.
Stroke, stroke, breathe.
- All right, let's take
a five-minute break.
- And when we come back, we gonna talk
about warming your bitch's
up before you get busy.
- And how to last for more
than two damn minutes.
- Take a peach and practice.
- Practice on a peach.
(sighs)
- Oh, I think it's gonna work.
- 30 down, 3 billion to go.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)